for the first time ever liquid water has
been discovered on Mars and the
significance of this discovery cannot be
overstated as it virtually guarantees
that life does indeed exist on Mars
today at least in some form based on
everything that we currently know about
the building blocks for life because
after all where there is water there is
life and in this video I'm going to
discuss key details about this discovery
and then connect the dots and other
really interesting pieces of information
about Mars that most people are just not
aware of this discovery comes at the
same time as a global sandstorm that has
engulfed the entire planet which I'll be
discussing later in this video but first
let me start by discussing the details
of the liquid water discovery which is
in the form of a massive underground
sublation lake located at the South Pole
of Mars and if your first thought is
wait this is an underground lake located
beneath the glacier why should we even
assume that the possibility of life
would exist there well we must first
remind ourselves of the 2014 discovery
at Lake Vostok in Antarctica where
scientists were shocked to find
microbial life thriving a half mile
below the Antarctic Ice Sheet
so compare that to the recent discovery
on Mars which is estimated to be one and
a half kilometers or just under one mile
beneath Mars is polar ice cap and this
data was collected through a scientific
study by Italian researchers that was
conducted between 2012 and 2015 where
they utilized satellite data from 29
radar pulses which indicated a body of
water possibly an aquifer or a reservoir
underneath the ice and this body of
water which is thought to be salt water
based on the fact that it is not frozen
is 20 kilometers wide or roughly 12 and
a half miles wide right now you're
probably wondering how we can identify a
body of water that is one mile beneath
ice all from a satellite that is
orbiting a planet well apparently there
is something called the Mars advanced
radar for subsurface and ionosphere
sounding instrument which is fixed on
the European Space Agency's
Mars Express spacecraft which
essentially bounces low-frequency radar
waves back and forth and identifies
changes in signal you know I'm not going
to pretend that I fully understand how
this technology works but it's almost as
if we've already created Star Trek type
technology where we use some type of
gadgets to search for life-forms or
whatever from a distance and of course
I'm being humorous here but I could see
how many people would doubt our
technological capabilities to know all
of this information about Mars having
never stepped foot on there to verify
its getting back to the significance of
this discovery there's water on Mars so
how can there not be life there some
people will mention the higher levels of
radiation on Mars which of course is an
obstacle for humans in our attempts to
travel to Mars safely but let's not
forget that we've discovered certain
bacteria that literally develop and
thrive inside of nuclear reactors which
of course was another stunning discovery
by scientists some years ago but another
indicator that life already exists on
Mars involves the changing levels of
methane emitting into space from the Red
Planet which even varies between seasons
now methane is not necessarily evidence
of the existence of life on Mars but it
is an indicator that some sort of
organic matter may indeed exist
currently on the planet now let's be
real many people myself included already
believe that life once thrived on Mars
at some point in the distant past and
there really is little reason to doubt
this considering that there is empirical
evidence of ancient lakes oceans rivers
and water channels existing throughout
the surface of Mars in fact scientists
state that it was likely three to four
billion years ago when life was
habitable on Mars which is an
interesting claim considering that we
haven't even stepped foot on the planet
and we really don't even know what the
surface of earth was like even just 1
billion years ago I mean some 300
million years ago there was the
supercontinent of Pangea which they say
broke apart about a hundred and
seventy-five million years ago but there
was also a supercontinent before Pangaea
called Rodinia that they say broke apart
approximately 700 million
years ago and I'm sure that scientists
are both right and wrong about different
aspects of the previous supercontinents
particularly when they existed but the
point is that according to them all of
this is less than 1 billion years ago
think about that seriously we have no
clue what was happening here on earth a
billion years ago and we can say with
any type of certainty what Mars was like
1 billion years ago much less 3 to 4
billion years ago now hold that thought
and think about this you may be aware
that there is currently an ongoing
global sandstorm surrounding the entire
planet of Mars which started on May 30th
and is expected to last four months
based on past observations and here you
can see a comparison of right before the
storm and how over the course of three
weeks it completely engulfed the planet
these storms seem to happen once every
five and a half years or so and here's
actually another example of a storm that
lasted for four months back in 2001 but
there are of course other examples of
massive dust storms on Mars that may not
engulf the entire planet but rather a
large portion of it and here you can see
an example from 2005 so I'm about to
reiterate a point that I've made in
multiple other videos involving the
evidence of ancient lakes rivers and
water channels on the surface of Mars so
if you've seen all my other videos bear
with me for a moment while I repeat
myself as I just can't discuss Mars
without making more people aware of this
important detail which is that how can
scientists state with the surface of
Mars was like 3 to 4 billion years ago
when there are routine stand storms
constantly changing the surface of Mars
I mean they give examples of a supposed
massive flood that happened on Mars 3
billion years ago yet virtually the
entire surface of Mars is covered with
the remnants of ancient Lakes riverbeds
and water channels so the question is
why haven't three billion years of
global sandstorms not eroded these away
is it possible that the surface of Mars
had water perhaps just thousands of
years ago like I said I've made this
point in other videos and the most
common response that I get is related to
the atmosphere on Mars being only 1% the
density compared to Earth's atmosphere
and they go on to mention how
the strength and the sandstorms of Mars
are not nearly as strong as depicted in
movies take the example of the movie the
Martian with Matt Damon which shows a
storm blowing with hurricane-force
strength when in reality the strongest
winds on Mars are limited to about
seventy miles an hour due to the lower
atmospheric density but scientists
themselves state that the sand particles
would still be moving at 70 miles an
hour even if the wind itself didn't
actually feel as strong as it would here
on earth
so although yes erosion on Mars occurs
much slower than here on earth it
doesn't change the fact that Mars still
has an atmosphere it's thick enough to
be observable from space and it is still
dense enough for these dust storms to
have sustained winds of 70 miles an hour
that engulf the entire planet for months
on end so of course that would cause
erosion all that sand moving in and out
of the ancient riverbeds should have
eroded the sides away into oblivion
billions of years ago so that is why
this particular detail of the existing
riverbeds and water channels is so
important when considering the
possibility that Mars may have been
habitable far more recently than
scientists suggest and by the way it's
not just sand storms on Mars but Mars
also has literally millions of dust
devils every single day and some of them
are massive
they've even observed one that was 12
miles high or 20 kilometres which is 10
times larger than the largest tornadoes
ever observed here on earth just not as
strong but if you're still not convinced
you should then consider the Phoenix
rover and the fact that it took less
than a decade to be almost completely
buried by the sands of Mars and this was
reported just a few months ago and you
can see photos here of the before and
after and I'm willing to bet that after
this current global sandstorm dissipates
this site will be completely buried and
non-existent
I'd also like to see before-and-after
photos of the various riverbeds located
throughout Mars to document just how
much they changed by this one storm
alone everybody should demand to see
what the data shows on that so yeah
I'm not afraid to say it I strongly
believe that the surface of Mars was
significantly different far more
recently than 3 to 4 billion years ago
in fact
probably far more recently than even
three to four million years ago that
aside we have to wonder what type of
life could exist on Mars today I bet all
my money that at a minimum microbial
life exists in the body of water that
was just discovered but could there be
small fish or crustaceans there as well
could there be insects around the area
this actually reminds me of articles
that were just published today and going
around the internet regarding the
discovery of worms and Siberia that were
brought back to life after being frozen
for 42,000 years I mean that's beyond
amazing and this is actually a real
eye-opener for what we thought was
possible and this gets me thinking and
makes me wonder what would happen if the
surface of Mars was to be fertilized
with just water alone it's been claimed
that no organic compounds have been
found in Martian soil but that of course
does not mean that they do not exist and
even with our Rovers we've only explored
a micro fraction of the Mars surface
it's also worth mentioning though that
liquid water has already been discovered
on Mars as a result of melting IceCaps
but the recent discovery of this massive
sub glacial lake at the South Pole
equates to a persistent body of water
that provides the conditions for life
for an extended period of time not just
melting runoff thus increasing the
probability life has actually developed
there ultimately it will not be until we
finally step foot on Mars before we get
any real answers as to whether life
actually exists there or not but before
I close this up it is interesting to
point out that today July 27th 2018 just
so happens to be the closest approach
that Mars and Earth have had with each
other in 15 years since 2003 this also
actually coincides with today being a
full moon but not just any full moon
there's going to be a lunar eclipse and
the so called Blood Moon will also be
visible this weekend so this is
definitely a big weekend for astronomers
and people that have an interest in the
cosmos but I'm gonna go ahead and leave
it at that leave me a comment to let me
know what your thoughts are and about
this recent Mars discovery as well as
the possibility for life existing there
now we're in the past but I'm Jimmy this
is bright insight hit the like button
and subscribe and I have many more
videos to come and a whole wide
variety of topics take care of everybody